[Music]
foreign
the Press preview a first look at what
is on the front pages time then to see
what is making the headlines with Sonia
Soda Chief leader writer at The Observer
and Matt datham home Affairs editor at
the times with us from now until just
before midnight so let's see what is on
some of those front pages then it's Mick
Grinch That's the lead on the front of
the Metro as rail Union Leader Mick
Lynch denies being a grinch stealing
Christmas from Travelers after
announcing a new wave of strikes front
of the eye then the headline Rebels for
soon act to back down on housing after
nearly 50 Tory MPS threatened to protest
over planning reforms The Daily Mail
also has the story about the unions
questioning when we will reign in the
Union's intent on Christmas Chaos
country that bans love the mirror
leading on a new development on the
route over gay rights in the world cup
over claims that England's Captain was
banned to not wear the one love armband
the financial times leading with the
latest on the FTX founder the paper says
he ran his crypto group as his personal
fiefdom before its recent implosion
the head of the NHS has said women will
be able to work from home if they are
experiencing bad menopausal symptoms
that's on the front page of the
telegraph
patients are refusing sick notes from
their GPS due to fears they can't afford
to take off time off work according to a
front page Guardian exclusive
there's a rising gambling addictions
with a surge of people turning up to a
and E's suicidal with the problem that's
in the Times Daily Star leads with Saudi
Arabia's shock footballing triumph over
Lionel Messi's Argentina leaving it the
biggest world cup upset ever
well a reminder by scanning the QR code
you'll see on screen during the program
you can check out those front page Pages
while you listen to our guests so let's
return to Sonia and Matt and um Sonia
let's go to the Metro first it's Mick
Grinch uh he of course denying he is
thus but certainly there'll be a great
deal of disruption with the latest dates
on offer from the rmt
that's right so new rounds of rail
strikes it's a set of four 48-hour
strikes so that'll be two before
Christmas to after Christmas to make
things worse as uh that period of
engineering work that always falls
between Christmas and New Year uh when
obviously people aren't commuting so
much for work but lots of people are
trying to get around the country to see
family so it's going to lead to tons of
travel destruction I'm sure lots of
people will do exactly what I did when
the dates were announced which is go and
have a look at my diary and find either
at least two days where I need to get to
other bits of the country where there's
going to be quite significant disruption
for me
um it's forecasts at one in five
Services we will run potentially even
fewer so it's going to make it very
difficult to get around the country and
then the period of engineering works is
going to make it very difficult as well
so I think you know I've got a lot of
sympathy with the real unions in terms
of what they're trying to get for their
members it's people who've experienced
real pay cuts some of whom you aren't
earning very much money if you're
talking about station staff over the
last uh decades those are paid cuts that
they can't afford but I think a question
for the rail unions is it's a tricky
line to sort of balance because up until
now I think the public has been quite
sympathetic and supportive of these
strikes everyone knows there's a massive
cost of living crisis on but I think
that the more that the disruption starts
to interfere with people's Christmas
plans and holiday plans um yeah the
harder it will be to keep the public on
side yes people have a lot of family
members to see don't they mad and many
people work over Christmas and New Year
shift workers you know nurses you name
it they have to see them elsewhere in
that festive period And The Daily Mail
pointing out too that Hospitality
achieves a warning that the strikes
would cost them millions of pounds at
one is one of the most lucrative times
of the year as they recover from the
pandemic and the worries about the cost
of living crisis
foreign
yes that's right and the first uh series
of strikes happening during that week
where I think most um companies hold
their Christmas parties uh the is it the
13th and 40th of December and the 16th
and 17th and uh spanning of that that
weekend where a lot of the social plans
will be affected as well and as you say
it's not um it is coming after two years
where uh families but also hospitality
industry as you said have been harshly
affected by covid restrictions and as
Boris Johnson and the um the government
found it's very you become very
unpopular when you start messing with
people's Christmas plans and I think big
Lynch um when he said uh this this
strike action will show just how
important Our Workers are I think it's
maybe a sign that maybe previous
historic action uh sort of failed really
um to win the argument for them because
with this era of remote working and
people you know being quite flexible
with working from home when there are
strike days it's not had the impact it
might have done before the pandemic
um and uh they're obviously resorting to
striking over Christmas period uh to try
and really Hammer home that impact and I
just think that might be a sign that the
rmt and possibly losing the argument
well we'll see certainly uh Mick Lynch I
nearly said Mick Grinch there because I
was reading the males and writing of it
anyway Mick Lynch
um suggesting that it's the government's
fault certainty and he's determined to
as he put it get a deal so we'll see
what happens next with that one but in
the meantime let's move on to the
guardian if we can Sonia
um doctors are warning that people are
refusing sick notes because they can't
afford not to go to work
yes so this is the new um GP leader uh
talking about what GPS are facing up and
down the country and it makes for some
pretty Grim readings there's what's in
the headline there which is that she
says in her experience and her
colleagues experience they're getting
people who really are chronically ill
who should not be going into work but
they're refusing sick notes because
they're saying that they just can't
afford not to go to work because
obviously
um you know lots of employers pay full
pay for a certain amount of time but not
all do and after a while you'll drop
down onto statutory sick pay which I
think is just over 100 pounds a week so
lots of people just can't simply afford
to be on that now that's really terrible
for people's long-term health and we
know we've got a big problem with
economic inactivity in this country at
the moment and that's because there's a
lot of long-term sickness following a
pandemic and people waiting for
treatments on the NHS and that really
starts to interfere not just with the
quality of people's lives but also with
um you know with economic growth it's
not the only thing that she talks about
she also talks about you know the sorts
of mental health distress she's seeing
coming into her surgery uh colleagues
are also reporting it
um you know people coming in with
vitamin deficiencies so symptoms like
feeling weak mouth ulcers because
they're just not eating properly they're
not getting proper nutrition from their
food and I think you know this really
does sort of highlight the extent to
which poverty is an increasing problem
in the country with the cost of living
crisis with the increasing Energy prices
there are some people who simply have to
make very difficult decisions between
can I afford to keep my home warm can I
afford to feed my kids do I need to give
up some meals in order for my kids to
eat really really difficult decisions
that really in a rich country people
shouldn't be facing so I think it's
another dimension of the cost of living
crisis that it's really starting to
impact on people's Health yes and news
of one Council who's extending a pilot
project where the NHS pays to heat
people's homes for those who become more
likely to enter Hospital if their homes
are cold people with COPD or severe
asthma or so and so a real indicator
they've had great success we'll indicate
to there that cold homes do make people
iller not to mention the pressure of the
fear of what's coming this winter on the
on their mental health mat
yes that's right and the guardian has
spoken to GPS one of whom is one that
because people because people are
becoming illa because the financial
crisis and whether it be through
increased mental health asthma breathing
problems the mouth ulcers as Sonya said
it's going to increase the pressure on
NHS longer term at the time when we have
major backlogs I think more than seven
million people are on waiting lists
currently so that just adds even more
pressure to the overburdened NHS and it
is really quite a worrying time as
especially as the temperatures really
dropped over the last week hasn't it
um so um it's going to be a harsh winter
whether it be train strikes whether it
be the financial crisis and health
problems yes and we seem to have that
warning from National Grid today which
was a subsequently rescinded about the
cold snap causing pressure you know on
on Power Systems um but the pressure on
the NHS is also included in this article
in the Daily Telegraph Sonia about out
menopausal women being able to work who
work in the NHS rather being able to do
their jobs from home if their symptoms
require it the telegraph suggesting that
this will put extra pressure at a time
when a record 7.1 million people are
stuck on NHS waiting list despite the
demand of of women for this to be
noticed more
well I think that's you know it's quite
a negative frame on the story in some
ways that the Daily Telegraph is put on
there I think this is actually quite
positive so it's all about looking after
your staff for the long term and we know
in the NHS you've got huge staffing
issues and part of that is due to
burnout um you know the we haven't been
training enough staff for the NHS over
the last decade ministers haven't done
enough planning around that staff
working in the service are getting
burned out and then they're leaving so
you've got to take care of your
employees for the long term to make sure
that doesn't happen it's very short term
to think oh well let's just make them
work more and more shifts and let's make
them work through ill health and other
health conditions and problems because
that's the only way to keep the NHS
going that's not the way to do it for
the long term I think this is very
positive we're having a much more
constructive conversation about the
symptoms of menopause as a society some
women go through menopause and it has no
impact on them at all and that's great
and fine some women do experience quite
profound symptoms as a result of the
hormonal changes and it is a real issue
I for gender equality in the workplace
about whether
um you know whether there are
adjustments made in the workplace for
the symptoms that women might experience
for example hot flashes but not just hot
flushes there's lots of other things
um that can go along with it so I think
this is a really positive story about
the NHS looking after its employees at a
time when actually lots of them are
burning out and leaving the service and
um you know as this article says the NHS
is the biggest employer of women in the
country and it should be setting an
example so I think it's obviously the
NHS has got lots of difficulties at the
moment around understanding but it is an
absolutely false economy to say well
let's just work all of our employees to
the Bone because I think in the medium
term that actually makes the Staffing
issue worse because they leave due to
burnout to politics now in the eye it's
also on the front page of the telegraph
this story Matt
um a Tory Rebellion uh the first for
Rishi sunak conceding to some 50 Rebels
about the idea of mandatory centrally
set housing targets to build 300 000
homes tell us more
that's right it's part of the wider
leveling up Bill but this uh really
contentious part which was due to the uh
debated on Monday
um would include plans to set a national
so the national Target to build 300 000
homes a year would have to be it'd be
mandatory for local authorities to take
into account that National Target when
deciding planning applications
um but uh Tory Rebels at 47 of them uh
put down an amendment that would have
just made that advisory and they really
opposed this top-down mandatory
um
imposition by the central government on
local authorities saying that this
central government should not be
deciding exactly where to build homes it
should be there's a lot of difference
across the UK and they should be it's
best for local authorities and local
councilors to make those decisions and
so in in the wake of this um the threat
of defeat on on Monday they've they've
pulled that um that particular debate I
think that the debate on tomorrow still
going ahead on the other parts of the
bill and Michael govewell and um he's
saying he's hoping to bring back the
contentious part before Christmas
um and in the meantime he hopes to win
over the rebels but I think this just
shows you uh that Rishi sunak um can't
he might have a 70 I think 71 seat
majority but he with 47 Tories about um
threatening to to vote against the
government on that even though labor
would not back that Amendment it just
shows you the power that backventures
have in this current Administration it's
fascinating isn't it yes Sonia I know
you want to talk about that we want to
get on to the rest of it I do apologize
maybe next time lots more still to come
the latest from Qatar as well and of
course the latest on Manu and Ronaldo
thank you
[Music]
well welcome back you're watching the
Press preview with me once again Sonia
Soda Chief leader writer at The Observer
and Matt dathan home Affairs editor at
the Times welcome back to both of you so
let's go to Qatar shall we Matt
um Daily Mirror continuing coverage if
we can talk about the continuing
controversy
um picking up a number of different
examples beyond the armbands not least
the word love which was due to be in the
collar of the Belgian teams top which
has also had to be removed and of course
the news last night that the rainbow
hats of the Welsh fans that were were
taken off them there we go there's an
example of one of them
yeah it's incredible really it led us to
which FIFA are going to ban any kind of
solidarity that countries and teams want
to show um for the LGBT plus Community
uh it was it was a subtle little word in
the collar which many of you wouldn't be
able to even see that the Belgium wanted
to weigh on to wear on its away kit and
then today we've learned the indeed more
details about just how much Harry Kane
and other captains were threatened if
they'd warned the the one love armband
um we I think the Danish fa uh revealed
today that uh captains were even
threatened with a one-match ban which um
is just quite incredible I can
understand FIFA not wanting countries to
be making political statements because
if you
allow one country to make a physical
statement it it might allow um open the
door to say Russia or other countries uh
maybe Israel or Iran making political
statements against other countries but
this isn't against the country this is
again this is supporting people's rights
to to be gay for example it's just it's
just quite astonishing just how much
FIFA we're going to to stop any kind of
uh gesture for fans and teams just just
quickly um Sonia as well I mean is there
some people saying there's some
hypocrisy here because you obviously
play cricket against Pakistan the other
newspapers the guardian the times all
celebrating the Saudis result against
Argentina with their you know really
questionable human rights record so you
know it it has um has cut Qatar had an
unfair focus on its records do you think
foreign
well I don't think so because it's very
different when they're the host's nation
um and you obviously face more scrutiny
on your human rights record if you're
you know rewarding a country as it were
by sort of giving them the competition
although obviously they have to spend a
lot of money on hosting it and I think
you know it's obviously the LGBT
um rights issue but there are also
massive issues in Qatar around women
women are not allowed to do quite a lot
within that Society without having male
Guardians sign it off things like travel
abroad for example
um so really serious rights issues there
and then there's also
um the the very high numbers of migrants
who've lost their lives in building that
stadium so I don't think it's unfair at
all actually
um I think what's quite interesting is
that the you know it the there are these
further details um emerging about about
threats that FIFA made I think there's
serious questions of FIFA about how they
award these competitions and then also
the way they conduct them and the way
that they've national football
federations but the guardian is actually
reporting today that the German Football
Federation is intending on taking FIFA
to um Court uh to sort of uh try and get
a legal uh uh you know a legal remedy to
um than Banning uh the German team from
wearing um the love symbols I think that
will be a very interesting one to watch